le prix de la nouvelle le salon des
visionnaires et exténué à
margaux oui
mais
c'est donc cette jeune étudiante de
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines où qui remporte le prix de la
nouvelle du salon du livre les
visionnaires très content très fier que
ce texte ait été entendu je suis fier de
ce que j'ai fait parce que je trouve que
j'ai vraiment assumé mon écriture et
c'était mon premier texte abouti en fait
écrit en ce moment un appel à écriture
lancé par le salon du livre aux
étudiants depuis le 1er mars sur le
thème imaginez vous la ville de demain
l'occasion pour margaux étudiante en
master littéraire décrire sa première
nouvelle cercle solaire c'est un peu à
un monologue théâtral poétique
6 y présente une ville enfouie sous
terre parce que le soleil a brûlé la
surface de la table une centaine
d'élèves ont pu participer à ce concours
évaluée autour de trois critères par les
membres du jury la pertinence par
rapport au thème parce que c'était
vraiment bien dans le sujet de la ville
de demain l'inventivité est ce que c'est
une intrigue attractive intéressante est
ce qu'on rentre dedans le style
l'écriture la qualité de du langage
savait que les étudiants de lettres à
l'airé gère bien sûr mais on ne pensait
pas que des étudiants viendrait donc
l'arrêt d'espagnol de 3 d'histoire et
dix premiers gagnants verront leurs
nouvelles publié un livre audio sera
réalisé dans les catalogues des
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines